well we begin with breaking news out of
London where police have arrested a man
after a stabbing attack at the Capitals
biggest mosque details are still
emerging but the victim a man in his 70s
who reportedly worked at the mosque has
been treated by paramedics and taken
it's a hospital let's go straight to
Laurie Laurie challon's who's on the
phone for us from central London Rory
what more can you tell us about this
incident we know about a couple of hours
ago a man came into the mosque and tried
as we understand it to be the imam of
the mosque and it wasn't successful in
doing that because someone else tried to
get in the way and stop this stabbing
and it was that person that ended up
being stabbed himself several times in
the neck what witnesses have said now
all the we understand at the moment it's
not absolutely now tamborim said that
this might have been the poison for the
for the mosque the man who calls the
prayers he has been taken to hospital
and his condition at the moment is not
thought to be life-threatening obviously
very serious injuries but not
life-threatening at the moment from what
we're being told and yes a man has been
arrested and on observation of attempted
murder so the fact that the latest has
been found at the moment we don't know
of course whether this is in any way
links to what happened in Germany over
the last day or so but that is going to
be forefront in people's minds at moment
but no no obvious connection so far and
this happened not too long ago Laurie
and police have not released any details
so far have they any ID any clue as to
who this perpetrator was no
identification of him so far thee you
know there are you want to go and look
kourin oh you want to go and look there
are video clips being shared on social
media twitter etc of police holding a
man down and then taking him out the
beach of the mosque and you can see he
looks like a white man but we don't know
anything else about him at the moment or
why he may have done this okay Rory
we've been just showing our viewers but
we're showing viewers that footage from
social media that we did have live
pictures from outside the mosque just
put this into context for us it looks
like a large mosque is this quite a
central place of worship in London is it
a busy mosque absolutely I mean for
anyone who knows London or you know the
life of Muslims in London this mosque
and another mosque in in Finsbury Park a
kind of the two main the teeth the two
most famous mosques in London so this is
one of the key centers for Islamic life
in in the UK a peak important part of
the fabric of something like this oh
yeah I'm sure it has felt itself to be a
target for you know any kind of
Islamophobic attack or any kind of
Islamophobic sentiment they probably had
a reasonably good security but you know
obviously the Pipers worship it didn't
need to be okay Rory challenge thank you
for now that's sir al-jazeera's Rory
challenge bringing us that breaking news
that a man is under arrest after a
stabbing attack at a large mosque in
central London we'll keep across that
story and bring you more details as it
comes out but for now let's say let's
get some analysis from talha Abdul Razak
he's a counterterrorism specialists
joins us now from London bye
go good to have you with us on the
program we're still waiting on the
specifics of this case filtering through
to us but as a counterterrorism expert
yourself could you just start by just
define you know what is terrorism
because we've had a we've had an attack
shooting attack target in Germany
whenever you know is this terrorism I
guess is my question
so I'm terrorism actually does not have
a kind of a globally accepted definition
so there's no commonality on the
understanding what definition it is so
the United Nations has a definition
various governments around the world
also also have their own definitions but
I mean it boiled down to its
fundamentals it's essentially the use of
violence to achieve political ends so if
we're looking at for example non-state
actors in particular all those states
themselves can be involved in terrorism
such as sponsoring terrorist
organizations but primarily here
especially when looking at people who
are kind of have a different worldview
radical worldviews militant worldviews
who have very strongly held opinions and
they believe that the only way to
achieve those ends those political hands
is through the use of violence and
that's why we see kind of commonalities
amongst the the tactics used to lies by
terrorists even if they are you know
nominally on opposite ends of the
ideological spectrum so you've got for
example Isis extremists using kind of a
knife attacks in the middle of a you
know Western capitals and you also have
fire art extremists
you know white supremacists also using
you know low-cost primitive attacks
involving knives and cars and knocking
people down and killing them so this
happens across the board and that's why
there's kind of a commonality in the
understanding of what terrorism is when
we see it but it's difficult to define
in and of itself well it appears to be a
commonality of understanding when you
look at who is conducting the attacks
and he's on the receiving ends of them
obviously the the people on the
receiving end of this attack are Muslims
in London does London have a problem and
does the UK have a problem but hate
hate crimes have been on the increase in
the United Kingdom particularly in
London there been a lot of instances and
plus you know we were seeing it
anecdotal evidence of video footage
social media video footage showing
Muslims on public transportation being
abused attacked hit spat on and you know
generally maligned this is actually as a
result of a highly charged atmosphere
against people of the Muslim faith
that's not to say that you know
obviously there aren't extremists within
Muslim communities that definitely are
and these people need to be challenged
but to demonize an entire community on
the actions of a few does not work in
fact encourages the same violence that
you're denouncing to actually find a
place to sprout and find fertile ground
to grow so it actually contributes to
the propaganda used by these extremist
groups you know if you have for example
just say this attack today if it is
linked to far-right extremism as it
seems likely at a preliminary level
right now then what that does is it
provides people like Isis and provides
people like al Qaeda with the propaganda
to say look you're not wanted in the
West new Muslims are people who are
hated by Westerners they don't want you
in their country they don't want you in
their homes they don't want you in their
cities and they are going to kill you so
you have to sign up with us to fight
back obviously such a warped ideology is
gonna take advantage of events like this
and similarly whenever Isis to commit a
terrorist attack you've got the
far-right on the other side
saying - you know what they call the
indigenous white population you know you
are under attack
you're being invaded there's a racial
war going on right now and you need to
soldier up and join the front lines to
defend your your livelihoods you need to
defend your homeland
so these ideologies actually feed each
other ok tell her Abdul Razak great to
get your thoughts thank you so much for
joining us there by Skype from London
well the